l'érection donc côté enseignement
catholique c'est le problème du statut
des maîtres qui ne passe pas on peut le
dire
côté laïque ce sont les politiques qui
semblent les plus réticents par exemple
monsieur andré laignel député ps juge
inacceptables les propositions de
monsieur savary sur l'enseignement privé
ils jugent ces propositions en dessous
de la barre acceptable par les laïcs
notamment l'obligation pour les communes
de financer les écoles privées
après les officiels pour avoir l'avis
des parents sur ce projet de réforme
ce matin nous avons demandé à notre
reporter jean pierre quinson de se
rendre sur le terrain dans les écoles ce
matin à paris le petit collège saint
louis de gonzague un établissement privé
du 16e arrondissement
au lendemain des propositions annoncées
par alain son mari
elles sont très loin d'y faire ici
unanimité
je pense que ne sont pas acceptables que
seront justement refusée par l'ensemble
des parents d'élèves libre pense
qu'elles ne sont pas encore suffisamment
clair et il faut attendre que la fin des
discussions entre le privé et
l'éducation nationale avant ça veut plus
pour qu'on puisse prendre une décision
définitive
un compromis fermé
et qui ne résout pas que cet essai
personne je n'ai pas mauvaise
pourquoi chez rien
parce que ça c'est une façon larvée et
hypocrite de d'étouffer al dans l'avenir
lancé devant lui avez vous le sentiment
que la liberté de choix est encore
menacée et menacer la en
on sent ce que on n'aura plus la
possibilité financière de mettre ses
enfants à l'école libre
vous pouvez décider un peu ça bon enfin
effacé des demi heures
oui et dans le second sens actuel des
jeunes en effet c'est chaque fois que
l'occasion s'en présente en pour les
enseignants du privé reste l'épineux
problème de la titularisation
fonctionnaires de l'état est ce que
c'est un statut que vous souhaitez
personnellement non pas particulièrement
être fonctionnaire non je ne souhaite
pas quelques minutes plus tard nous
sommes rue lacordaire une école primaire
publique du 15e arrondissement
moi je suis pour les deux systèmes c'est
vrai je suis pour l'enseignement laïc et
un grand système laïque est aussi vain
que c'est ce qu'ils peuvent pas se faire
réussir dans des structures nationales à
il un peu dans du privé si je trouve
leur bonheur là dedans mais en tant que
défenseurs de la laïcité
vous avez le sentiment d'avoir gagné
quelque chose au banc pour grand chose
quand on gagne quelque chose mais pas
gagné grand chose